hey everyone i'm john coogan and welcome
to the fifth part of my guide to startup
fundraising
in the last video i talked about how to
pitch your company with an effective
deck
and now i'm going to go through how to
close a deal meeting with an investor
is all about convincing them that you're
building a great business
so once they agree that you are making
customers happy growing the customer
base significantly every month
and are operating in a huge market they
will want to do a deal
before you focus on any legal documents
you need to outline the terms of the
deal verbally or over email
to make sure everyone is in agreement
the best way to do this is to follow
what's called the handshake deal
protocol
here's how it works first you define the
offer
something like an investor putting in a
hundred thousand dollars at a five
million dollar post money valuation
meaning that the money invested is
included in the valuation of your
company
once the investor agrees and says i'm in
for 100k at a 5 million dollar post
you need to confirm by saying the exact
offer back to them
so you're in for 100k at five million
dollar post
then you need to send an email or a text
message to the investor
saying this is to confirm that you're in
for 100k
at a 5 million post please confirm
within 48 hours
and agree to fund your investment within
10 business days once the investor
confirms
they are in the round and you now have
an obligation to finalize the deal with
them
this might seem cumbersome but it's
really important because of how messy
fundraising can be
often times there are lots of
conversations going on with investors
simultaneously
and many investors like to wait as long
as possible to make a final decision
you really want to avoid situations
where an investor who you thought was
out comes back to you just as you're
closing the round and says that they
expected to be included
i encourage you to read the full blog
post by y combinator on the handshake
deal protocol that have linked below in
order to really understand why it's
effective
after you have investors committed
you'll need a legal document to confirm
the transaction
investments can be made as equity sales
debt agreements or
safes which is what we're going to focus
on today the safe
or simple agreement for future equity
was introduced by y combinator
in 2013 as a way to streamline early
stage startup fundraising
since then it's exploded in popularity
and almost entirely replaced the
convertible notes that were popular
before
before we get into exactly what a safe
is and how to use them effectively
let's go over some startup history in
the first decade of the 2000s
most seed rounds were done via priced
equity securities
but convertible notes took over in 2010
and became the dominant financing
vehicle
they were much faster to execute than
equity rounds but because they were debt
they typically had interest payments
attached that often became cumbersome
for startups
y combinator has focused on reducing
headaches for early-stage companies so
that they can focus on building great
businesses
investors have tons of experience doing
deals whereas first-time founders don't
typically have experience or know what
to expect
i've heard lots of horror stories from
founders who raised money early
outside of silicon valley on
non-standard terms and wound up giving
away
over 50 percent of the equity before
even getting to market yc
acts somewhat like a union for early
stage founders
by publishing standard documents and
outlining what founders should expect
from investors
they level the playing field a bit and
stop these terrible deals from happening
predatory investors who insist on
non-standard investment terms are easier
to identify
when you can benchmark their demands
against public documents available on
yc's website
and it's not just startups that have
been plagued by complex and harmful
legal documents
kanye west recently published all 10 of
his universal contracts
in a massive series of tweets in an
attempt to shine a light on how major
labels can hurt musicians with complex
agreements
he actually said that he wants to create
a y combinator for the music industry
to give artists more transparency and
prevent lifelong deals from holding back
promising careers
when it comes to creativity either in
startups or the music industry
no legal contract should limit your
ability to execute effectively
i hope that more industries start
adopting standard contracts and
publishing guidelines for how to close
deals in a fair way
i recommend using safes when fundraising
for a few key reasons
at five pages the safe is very
straightforward as far as financing
documents go
nearly every experienced startup
investor has used a safe before
there aren't many points to negotiate
since everything is so standardized
and lastly it's not a debt instrument so
investors can't ask for their money back
or demand interest if you haven't raised
a series a yet
a standard safe contains just five
sections the first
describes what happens in different
situations like a series a
acquisition ipo or even bankruptcy the
second section
outlines definitions for the contract
the third and the fourth are
representations by the company and
investors that essentially state that
each side can legally participate in the
investment
and the last section is just legal
boilerplate the entire document is very
readable
so i recommend reading all five pages
before you fundraise
the safe is designed to standardize as
much of the investment process as
possible
so you should only need to be
negotiating the amount of the investment
and the valuation cap
the investment amount is how much the
investor will actually be sending you
and the valuation cap is the maximum
valuation that the safe will convert
into equity at
if you wind up raising your next
valuation below the valuation cap
your previous safe investors will get a
larger portion of the company so be
aware of that
it's standard practice to use post money
safes now so that makes calculating the
investment amount very straightforward
if an investor signs a safe for a 1
million investment at a 5 million
post money valuation cap you have
essentially just guaranteed them at
least
20 percent of the company since most
fundraising rounds will involve multiple
investors
it's really important to keep track of
what you've promised so you know how
much equity you still own
you can do this in a spreadsheet or in a
software like cap table i o or carta
but regardless of how you choose to
track things make sure you are always
aware of how much
you will own of the company after
fundraising it's extremely easy to lose
track of dilution
and there's really no way back to owning
more of the company once you've executed
safes with investors the goal of the
safe is to be simple and standardized
but there is some variety
first the safe itself can be structured
to have a valuation cap
only meaning that the investor will know
up front
what percent ownership of the business
they are getting second
you can have a discount with no
valuation cap meaning that the investor
will essentially be investing in the
next round
at a reduced price but that valuation is
dependent on
the next round's price third you can
have both a valuation cap
and a discount meaning the investor gets
whichever is most advantageous
and lastly there is the most favored
nation safe
which lets investors start with an
uncapped no discount safe
but convert to better terms if they are
offered to other investors
investors can also ask for side letters
that give them extra rights beyond what
the standard safe would
you need to be careful about these since
some side letters can have dramatic
impacts
a side letter that grants information
rights so an investor can report data to
their limited partners
is usually fine but a side letter that
grants a board seat or super pro rata
could significantly change the
relationship with this particular
investor
here are some examples of side letters
that you will want to discuss with your
team and potentially a lawyer if you
don't fully understand the trade-offs
some of these can block your ability to
sell your company down the road or make
series a investors less interested in
funding the company
these clauses used to slip into
financing agreements all the time
without much oversight
but now that the safe is so common
founders have to explicitly understand
what they are agreeing to
part of what makes the safe so resilient
to tricky additions is the second line
it basically says that both the company
and the investor agree not to deviate
from what yc has published on their
website
if you ever see this line missing from a
safe you can be sure that the clauses
below have been altered and you will
need to review it very carefully
so to summarize in most situations it's
best to use a standard post-money safe
with a valuation cap and no discount
once you're comfortable advancing from
handshake deals to safe closings
you can start to deal with requests for
side letters or different terms as they
come in
if it's a big investor who you are
really excited to work with it might
make sense to deviate from the standard
terms
but always consider what that will mean
for other investors you don't want to
wind up in a cascading situation where
you keep giving extra favorable terms to
more and more investors
in the next video i'm going to talk
about what changes for your business
after closing a financing round
so be sure to hit the subscribe button
and ring the bell if you want to be
notified when that goes live
and if you think i left anything out
please leave me a comment below
thanks for watching